obviously not too much to stay um
obviously we didn't do anything well
enough today to deserve to win so
um
we'll be playing next week and we'll see
who that is and
and
still have opportunity in front of us
here so
need our best football and we didn't
have it today
but hopefully we'll be there next week
well he's still the same win lose ty
whatever in out whatever the same happy
go lucky he's not happy he's not lucky
he doesn't go as jerry seinfeld once
said bill belichick
falls from the two spot chris sims to
the three spot and what a difference
that is for the new england patriots
first time they will play
wild card weekend since the 2009 season
when they lost at home in that early
sunday spot
33 to 14. right ray rice right rough
shot right right on the game he brought
right up the middle for like it was over
why are we even here right that's the
last time the patriots played in the
wild card round they're back there and
they had the tennessee titans who
punched their ticket with a victory over
a texas team that really wasn't trying
to win but the titans they're built to
go into foxborough
and beat the patriots i'm not saying i'm
not good i'm not throwing dirt yet no no
no we've already established the
patriots or the terminator yes they are
and they are not dead until you are damn
sure they are dead right and until that
metal body has been dismembered and the
parts distributed all over the globe and
maybe some into outer space even then
they may not be dead
no i'm with you but this is th this this
is unlike any team we've seen of the
patriots in the last 10 years that since
that team made a 16 and a half point
favorites to beat the dolphins to get
that by they knew the stakes this wasn't
some hiccup this wasn't some accident
they knew what they were up against they
knew they needed this game and they
couldn't get it done and that is
alarming inconsistencies on offense as
we know the defense which has been great
all year especially stephon gilmore he
was attacked yesterday for the first
time we've seen really all season by
devante parker what does bryan flores
know about stefan gilmore that
emboldened the dolphins to attack him
the way they did there had to be
something he's picked up working with
this guy saying here's how you beat him
this is what you do well this is the guy
maybe the guy you hope he covers and
we're going to throw we're not going to
be scared of him we're going to throw it
this way we're going to put the ball
here we're going to make him do this he
knows his weaknesses yeah well it
definitely does definitely knows his
weaknesses and then this is really the
story of the game too
the dolphins got an early field goal
brady throws a pick six lets the
dolphins get up ten nothing and all of a
sudden they got the confidence to go
whoa we can play this game we can win
this game but to your point mike with
gilmore too i think the biggest thing is
they have a belief they realize okay
we're out man this defense is better
than us where's one area we feel good
about and they feel good about devontae
parker they think he's a superstar now
this is a bunch of coaches that love
devontae parker when they were working
for the new england patriots and i just
think they looked at it more of like
this is a strength of ours more than
just attacking a weakness of gilmore i
think they said fitzpatrick's good at
throwing we're not going to shy away all
right we're not going to shout out what
are we who cares if we lose this game
but we're not going to shy away from the
good things that have gotten us you know
four wins up to that point until
yesterday where it was their fifth win
and i think that was more of the thing
than anything they just looked at that
and said okay we know we're getting
man-to-man over here our quarterback's
aggressive he'll throw back shoulders
and be aggressive and keep throwing to a
guy who's covered and this guy he can
get open or when he is covered he can
make great catches and i just think they
went to the well on that and i think
that was more than any more than
anything of just as far as picking up a
gilmore weakness or anything like that i
wonder if that's part of psychology
though when you're talking about a
corner who is getting to the point where
he's accustomed to not being tested no
doubt all of a sudden it's not one of
these games where they're staying away
from it's like hey they're actually
throwing it at me what do i do you're
you're there is something to that there
you're those guys are usually used to
like okay if i'm just close to the guy
or if i get up here and bump man-to-man
coverage
i'm stefan gilmore i'm you know darrell
rivas back in those days people just
said ah forget it we'll just go to the
other side of the football and not even
mess with that guy but the dolphins said
the hell with that they just said hey we
just re-extended this devonte parker
he's a first-round pick and we're gonna
see what you got stefan gilmore and as
you saw on some of those highlights
there so many of the balls were just you
know okay great position by stefan
gilmore but we're going to throw the
ball behind devonta parker and like
eight feet up in the air and he'll just
jump and put his long arms up in the air
and snag it and it was just a lot of
those type of plays ryan fitzpatrick
gutsy performance by him as usual and
the patriots you know they ran the ball
well yesterday there's something wrong
with brady's arm you can see it you see
him shaking out the elbow that is to me
and i've had this before too like when
you throw and you do this that's
tendinitis elbow like you're always
trying to shake it like oh that's
bothering me let me try to shake it out
my arm it's broken yeah i think it's
broken uh so i there is an issue there
and i think the biggest context school
we had is what they did at the end of
the first half which we talked on sunday
absolutely right absolutely explain what
happened well sunday i mean last night
we did a little segment on this but
there's there's a minute and 48 left
it's third and ten with the miami
dolphins they run a run play to
basically say we're not going to let
ryan fitzpatrick throw it here and throw
an interception and let the patriots
gain some confidence so minute 48 they
run the ball in third and 10 punt it new
england didn't take the time out after
third down that was the first time we
were like why wouldn't they take the
time out all three right all three time
out so we're thinking okay maybe they're
just saving the timeouts for the
offensive side of the ball they run the
ball on first down don't take a timeout
run the ball again on second down they
just go in at half to me to where it was
like either one belichick was like ooh
the offense is shaky and i don't trust
tom right now to make throws or whatever
or he's just going tom's elbow is not
great and i don't think he can push the
ball down the field here to get us in
the field goal position very odd because
that was the ultimate belichick moment
they usually go down kick a field goal
they got the ball to receive the second
half and you're thinking there's going
to be a 10 point swing and that 10 point
swing never happens sometimes it's a 14
point swing yeah sometimes you see a two
touchdown advantage that comes out of
that end of the first half possession
start of the second half possession but
but you're right there was a strategic
decision there nothing happens
accidentally with bill belichick the
master of situational football he gets
what he wants and what he wanted there
was to get the hell off the field and
get to the locker room before they run
the risk of making it worse and that is
a rarity for the new england patriots
again i'm not saying that any of this
means they're done because the moment
that we all stand up in unison and say
they're done is the moment that they're
going to start engraving their names
onto the next lombardi trophy they want
us all i'm not taking the bait i've done
it before i'm not going to declare them
done i am going to be well i hear you by
saying that they're going to win it all
before i'm going to be wrong by saying
they're done i i get you i mean it's
it's it's it's impossible to pick
against the patriots not when we've seen
you know 19 years of dominance and we
know they can bounce back but and they
thrive for single elimination they
definitely do there's nobody that can
break down teams and bring out trick
plays and do things that you'd never
think of in a one game you know win or
you're done go home type of scenario
than the new england patriots but
they're different than years past
because they have to play a little bit
conservative on offense brady at 42 and
his arm issue right now certainly not
capable of carrying the team that way
there's no big time receiver julian
edelman's got a little bit of case of
the drops this year too that's an issue
you know they ran the ball okay
yesterday they definitely did that
they've it's been better as of late but
you know they're they're they're
they're not one of the two best teams in
the afc i know that i can say that for
sure
i'm not saying the patriots won't go to
the super bowl but i can say for sure
that they are not as good as the ravens
and the kansas city chiefs right now
definitely not they have to play the
game a certain way
and if it gets to be too many points
like 27-24 is about the limit for the
patriots as we saw yesterday it's about
the limit and that's you know against
the dolphins defense that's not that
good so that just shows you again
playoff football their defense might
have to be like 20 is the limit 17 is
the limit they're going to have to win
games that way and new england's loss
was kansas city's gain because as
the patriots were losing at home to the
dolphins the chiefs were pulling away
from the charges it was a game early on
that looked like it might go sideways
for the keys but they pulled it together
and it was a great moment and kevin
harlan was calling
for cbs the chiefs chargers game while
also simultaneously doing play-by-play
off-screen
of the go-ahead touchdown late by the
dolphins because that was extremely
relevant to the chiefs that opened the
door to the bye week it opened the door
to a home game in the divisional round
just like last year when they beat the
colton and they are they are an upset of
the ravens away from hosting the afc
championship game for a second straight
year if they can hold serve against the
patriots or whoever they see in that
opening round it will be the patriots as
the three seed or
the uh the winner of the four five game
the texans bills if there would be an
upset of the patriots by the titans in
the wild card round so chiefs are
amazing chiefs chiefs are amazing me
called hardman they drafted him in round
two in anticipation of the possibilities
tyree kill may not be available they
have hill they have hardman they still
have sammy watkins the offense is
overlooked yeah defense has improved
right giving up 21 points yesterday was
the most points they've given up in
weeks but but that defense is at the
point where they're ready to play
january football the offense is the
point where they can get it done and
this is the team that i think
everybody's been overlooking they should
not be overlooked going into the post no
i'm with you there i mean to me they're
they're playing they're more like
playoff caliber like orchestrated
football team this year than compared to
last year and i think yesterday again
not their best football the chargers
have been a pain in the butt for the
kansas city chiefs as we saw in mexico
city or the chargers upset them last
year late in the saturday night football
game and the end of the season they're
they play a certain style that's tough
on kansas city but kansas city to me the
encouraging thing is they're showing a
lot of different ways to win football
games yesterday again another big win
without patrick mahomes having to throw
for 350 yards and four touchdowns they
did it with defense special teams and
the run game and then mahomes made a few
plays here and there but i think that's
encouraging to this team where okay yeah
you might have to go into baltimore and
you know it might not be able to throw
for 400 yards in that game are you going
to be able to find other ways to move
the ball and make the plays and i think
kansas city chiefs over the last like
five to six weeks have shown that they
are capable of doing that
and and uh
they've beaten the ravens twice with
lamar jackson not that that means
anything when we get to they match up
good with the ravens and and uh
that we've seen that one seed stumble
and in recent years the one seeds and
the two seeds have done well in the
division around but in both conferences
this year maybe we're going to see that
change especially with the ravens
resting their key starters but still
handling the steelers impressive and
very impressive fashion finishing 14-2
the best team in the league uh clearly
and the best team in the conference but
that all gets wiped clean it doesn't
matter now the regular season's over
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports